seguimos hablando de fútbol y por ello
Saludos Sara Castro directora de
deportes de Caracol radio y del diario
Colombia bienvenida a un año más a
deportes domingo Hola Juanes un gusto
estar para mí además en año de mundial
femenino Así es muchísimos eventos
tenemos este año no todo es el mundial
masculino de fútbol Sara vamos a
analizar un poco las grandes ligas de
Europa Empezando por la liga de
Inglaterra en la que estamos viendo que
a mí que la arteta ya le está tomando
mucha forma y muy buena forma ese
proyecto suyo para mí la palabra que
acabas de decir es clave proyecto es
inicia el cuarto año arteta al frente
del Arsenal y creo que él ha logrado
llevar esos pasos que son necesarios
para la construcción de un equipo el
primero definió una cultura de una
identidad de juego que son absolutamente
identificables luego consiguió tanto
proyectar como conseguir jugadores que
se amoldaran a ese a ese estilo de juego
a esa idea que él tenía Y a partir de
ahí construyó una confianza Yo creo que
el rendimiento que estamos viendo en
jugadores como bodegard como Shaka como
sinchenko que muy bien a este a este
estilo y esta idea son el producto de un
equipo que ha logrado Identificar y
llevar a cabo en estos años esos
procesos que son necesarios para luego
plasmarlo en el campo de juego lo que
vimos hoy ante el Manchester United fue
la capacidad uno de reponerse la
adversidad Pero además de ser
consecuentes con esa idea que tienen
vemos un equipo muy con mucha movilidad
que aprovecha los espacios que deja el
rival creo que es un equipo que si bien
tiene un juego posicional que hoy en día
está siendo cuestionado creo que deja
mucho a la imaginación a la creatividad
de esos grandes talentos que tiene y en
eso se construye esa idea de arteta que
sin duda apostó muy grande al irse del
lado de Pep para crear su propia idea y
creo que lo estamos viendo muy
identificable en este Arsenal sin duda
alguna Los favoritos al título hablando
un poco más de Europa vamos a salir de
Inglaterra vamos a Italia porque el
Napoli camina con paso muy firme para el
título en español Barcelona se está
ilusionando también con el Campeonato
mientras que en Francia el psg es el que
está generando algunas dudas empecemos
por Italia Yo creo que la de spalletti
en este Napoli es bastante interesante y
sobre todo emocionante hemos visto un
equipo que desde que él llega en medio
de una unas críticas muy grandes porque
se iban los grandes referentes del
equipo y lo primero que hizo fue hacer
una transición hacia un equipo mucho más
joven y creo que los equipos los equipos
jóvenes a los cuales se les dio con una
idea Clara de juego y una motivación
empiezan a verse un poco conquistados
por esa idea y creo que eso es lo que ha
logrado espagueti que si bien no tiene
títulos de liga en Italia si es un
técnico que tiene muchísima experiencia
fue campeón de copa en Italia fue a
Rusia creo que es un un técnico que
conoce muy bien este tipo de
competencias y lo logró haciendo hacer
imponiéndose desde las primeras fechas
del Campeonato se ha logrado sostener
ante equipos que le han presentado por
supuesto cara como el inter que vienen
ahí persiguiendo pero que los veo muy
intermitentes al interior Milán Y luego
el aroma de mourinho que si bien ha
tenido grandes partidos también está en
ese proceso de adaptarse y yo creo que
esto tiene que con lo que mencionaba
anteriormente cuando se hablaba del
Arsenal Y es que los equipos necesitan
tener convicciones en la idea y en lo
que se cree recordemos que el Napoli no
ha sido campeón no ha ganado el escudo
desde la época de Maradona 87 y 90 O sea
que esto representa muchísimo para una
ciudad muy futbolera Luego pasamos al
Barcelona que también viene en ese
proceso mire que hace hace ocho días
hace una semana mencionaba que él más
que la táctica valorada de su equipo la
capacidad de responder de ser resiliente
y yo creo que toda esa resiliencia viene
de esos conceptos que empiezan a darse y
a fortalecerse en los equipos el Barça
después de muchas dificultades que hemos
analizado aquí de tipo institucional
deportivo y demás creo que Xavi ya ha
empezado a encontrar el equipo y si bien
no es el equipo que él aún desea digamos
este Barça no ha logrado su pico de
rendimiento si empieza a encontrar uno
un técnico que ha tenido que adaptarse a
lo que tiene dos figuras relevantísimas
como son Pedri Gaby en este cambio Y
luego ter stegen como esa base también
en la defensa y más de desde el punto de
vista de ese liderazgo que tal vez
busquets no está pudiendo tener por las
complicaciones en el juego que tiene
este Barcelona por lo menos en esa
posición desde el mediocentro entonces
Barça hace la tarea también en un Real
Madrid que encuentre se encuentra en esa
curva de rendimiento en la cual es
intenta adaptarse yo creo que la
supercopa le vino bien a la hora de
retomar confianza también y y sobre todo
de darle un golpe a su a su digamos a su
competidor más cercano y Súper
interesante seguir lo que está haciendo
la Real Sociedad que no solo es tercero
sino que con un equipo
dirigido por Imanol que que sin muchas
figuras pero con ese estandarte como es
David Silva creo que va a dar mucho de
que hablar en España en esta temporada y
un apunte de lo que estamos viendo del
psg que está también algo está sufriendo
en la liga yo creo que más que sufrir
ahí es un equipo que tiene mucha presión
en el tema de Champions y y en Cómo
sacar rédito a tener estas grandes
figuras este lunes tiene un partido copa
en el que Messi va a descansar si
estarán convocados en papel y Neymar y
creo que están es más en ese proceso de
entender cómo la liga al final resulta
ser que que la pueden definir con este
tipo de talentos y figuras Yo creo que
un poco es el proyecto Pues el psg en
general con toda esta inversión con todo
este mercadeo y todo lo que representa
en el mundo fútbol que además esto nos
da pie para lo que vamos a hablar más
adelante todo lo que está pasando Cómo
se pone Cómo se pone a prueba para
lograr este gran título a nivel europeo
que creo que es a lo que le apunta ya
este proyecto efectivamente vamos a
tratar otro tema que estamos viendo en
esta temporada como el mundo de los
países del Golfo está buscando
posicionarse como una potencia a nivel
mundial vimos el mundial de Qatar vimos
la supercopa de España italiana Arabia
Saudita incluso la supercopa nueva
internacional de Argentina en emiratos
árabes Unidos y Incluso hoy coincidiendo
con el debut de Cristiano Ronaldo con el
al nacer oficialmente yo creo que más
que naciones futboleras lo que hemos
identificado es que estos países han
querido potenciar su poder económico
hacia otros lugares es decir quieren
lograr influencia cultural política y
eso lo logran a través del deporte más
popular como es el fútbol entonces por
eso hemos visto estas contrataciones que
lo que hacen es poner los ojos del mundo
hacia allá por supuesto hay unos temas
desde el punto de vista de Derechos
Humanos éticos y demás que se ponen de
presente a la hora de llevar estos
torneos hacia esos lugares a mí para mí
hay dos cosas que son importantes uno el
mundial de Qatar nos demostró que el
fútbol no es de los mismos siempre y
creo que nos permitió ver como estos
Países Árabes y muchos países digamos
emergentes podían ser protagonistas en
este tipo de torneos pero a la hora de
llevar torneos de equipos de Clubes a
este tipo de lugares yo creo que sí se
corre un riesgo muy grande porque si
bien el negocio económico podría parecer
bastante potente creo que se pone en
riesgo lo más relevante del fútbol que
es esta conexión con la hinchada con sus
hinchas
los mundiales podemos rotar estas sedes
pero a la hora de hablar de torneos que
tienen un carácter local y de afinidad
con la afición creo que ahí el riesgo es
muy es muy latente Pero esto nos daría
por para varios programas